he needs to beat jordan with black
pieces otherwise you win
yeah it's pretty good uh because before
this round it felt like almost
impossible i mean it
i mean
several people had to do certain results
which was kind of unexpected
um yeah we
enjoyed that we'll enjoy the show
we will definitely enjoy the show so i
say take it away guys because we're
running
the show has started liam if he wins
this game he will win the tournament any
other result means duda wins the oslo
esports cup what's happening on the
board it's already about to be fire on
the board we have seen the open spanish
and look at this black has just given up
a night and okay pushing a pawn this is
one of the sharpest lines in opening
chess and it's so trendy actually the
two players they battled out in this
opening earlier today already so
in that game liam had the advantage
who knows what's going to happen right
now white has a bishop and a knight for
black's broken pawn but look at the
white king out into the open liam has
done the right thing good opening choice
and duda is uh definitely paying
attention to this together now with
anish giri pacing a little bit he will
be nervous looking at this young
christophe duda
what a tense finish we will have to the
tournament juden looks calm he of course
knows as well with a with a draw in this
game we will head to tie breaks between
these two
but jordan can of course also win this
match
yup jordan can win this match and of
course he'll want to win this match and
actually when these two faced each other
just a couple of games ago it was this
opening and jordan won so uh jordan
remember he's on site with his second
johan sebastian christensen he would
have been working away tapping the
computer
checking what the computer says about
this opening liam he's here alone yeah
he doesn't he i think he was going to
come with his wife but that didn't
happen in the end so uh
that's a big advantage to jordan to in
this extremely sharp position i mean
there's not even much point talking
about how we got to this because this is
just theory it's one of those things you
either know or you don't play you just
avoid it like the play because it's so
sharp one bad move and you lose i expect
the computer's assessment of roughly
equal is fair but it's not a draw
there's so much going on here it's
anything other than a draw and for liam
in a must win situation if he wants to
win the tournament it makes a lot of
sense to go for this type of position so
imbalanced so many lines open towards
that white king and liam as black
it's not easy to win but he's got a good
kind of foundation for that
and uh jordan will have to answer some
serious questions about that white king
later in the game and everyone in the
oslo arena will be paying attention to
this right now let's head back to the
lounge and hear from anish geary
you were laughing right now on this
because it was
jordan who's actually playing for a win
it seems yeah and i was uh joking
without christopher because
if uh jordan was team team duda
or at least
got already the money transfer but it
seems that jordan's the money hasn't
arrived at the jordan's account so he's
he he of course doesn't know doesn't
want to secure the first place for uh
duda what is the point he wants to win
his own match so he's playing for a win
uh against an opening where you can play
very safe and make a draw so you're
playing for win means of course there
are chances for the quank
and that's interesting because obviously
these are two people with very very
different incentives right now
yeah
i think it's very very good for do that
that jordan is
yeah is fighting and he has motivation
to win this game of course
when you have one half and a half you
know there's a lot on the line always
you know so with white you want to push
for a win and yeah i'm curious uh i'm
curious what to happen
um
i i still think that uh white you know
from the start always opening always
looks good for it so i think that dude
is a favorite now but uh we'll see
you'll see it's very exciting finish i
didn't even know like at some point i
saw the stats few days ago it was like
50 for magnus 30 for or 38 like for
prague and i assume that this is going
to be two horse race but already earlier
i remember one time
when i played vikanze before last round
i saw the stats and jordan had four
percent i had a much much higher and
other people had also hired and finally
he won the tournament with these four
percent so this uh percentages they
they're deceiving
but one thing's for sure i don't think
duda wants jordan over pressing now for
that win
absolutely we do have a few moves on the
board what does this look like we have a
few moves and it's so difficult to
explain what's going on in this position
because it is so chaotic and a niche
there i was interested to hear his uh
analysis he was like oh it's a safe
opening you can play for a draw with
white
there's pieces all over the board
white's king danced up the board
retreating maybe if you're a super
grandmaster who studied this position
for dozens of hours with a computer then
you can say okay it's pretty safe for
white but that white king is very very
open
i would never dream of touching i'll
tell you an interesting statistic
according to my database you know
basically nearly all the games end in a
draw
as we've learned from his chessboard
courses
but okay a queen trade from liam taking
that pawn with the queen trading queens
now i understand why maybe it's going to
be a draw i thought liam with uh with
that kind of must-win situation
tournament within his grasp he would
keep the queens on but no trading the
queens and suddenly we see a scenario
where black has a rook and two pawns
that's worth seven points for white's
bishop and knight worth six but white's
minor pieces are very very strong in
this end game
predictions guys a draw i'm just i'm
just going by the stats here i can see
that in this
database of maybe 50 games
i i think about 45 of them have ended in
draws and two have ended in black
victories and the rest wins for white
okay so some black victories in there
liam needs to hope for a black victory
if he wants to win the tournament look
at jordan's clock he's actually gained
two minutes from when they started and
we're at move 22 now and it's still
theory that's modern chess these players
have studied this position before yeah
it's a little bit sad really
i mean well it's not sad it's just how
chess is in the modern the modern age
you don't need to think sometimes until
you get to mu 20 but you don't have to
play like this i mean you can play like
david as well and by by that i mean
you don't really follow theory i mean
you actually avoid it very early on and
you just play chess so it's it's i'm
actually surprised that liam lee has
gone for this line i know it's all
tactical it's all complex but if it's
known to lead to equal positions why not
just do something else a sicilian
something like this well here comes the
new move
everyone
in the database has actually played rook
takes rook and they've played out that
in-game here liam is like no i'm going
to push harry
and always a good move according to
simon if you don't know what to do
always always a good move yeah but maybe
we can jump in just to show what's
happening in the position because we did
mention it was wild earlier but this is
still i mean i say opening theory we're
pretty much in an end game now uh but uh
after this last pawn push a new move
there normally black was actually taking
the white rook we saw jordan he's the
one to capture the rooks off the board
so we see this material imbalance these
bishops balance each other out let's
ignore them for a moment black has the
rook and these two pawns neither of
which are past pawns but in return white
has a bishop and knight and especially
this bishop is just a fantastic piece
it's on an outpost it can never ever get
kicked away it kind of covers these
squares covers these squares the white
knight still needs to do some work to
get active maybe liam trying to push
pawns towards it to try and kick it away
but i'm expecting a simple move from
jordan now the most natural move in the
position stepping forward with the white
king hitting the black bishop and the
problem here for liam is how do you keep
this bishop alive the last thing you
want to do is offer a trade here
because suddenly two bishops will nearly
always beat one lone rook
and uh okay he doesn't go for the most
natural move uh attacking this bishop
with the white king instead jordan
brings his bishop forward attacking the
rook instead and attacking this pawn
another very interesting option there
and the problem for black is you want to
get active with this rook that is
threatened but where do you put it if
you bring it down the whole way to give
a check to the white king then whoops
you walk into a double attack and uh if
you can't find active squares for that
rook you might be in trouble ivanka
which side would you rather be here
would you rather be white or black if
you had to pick a side to be i would
rather be white white because the two
minor pieces because of the two minor
pieces and the fact that they control so
many squares but i would say if black
manages to trade off a set of minor
pieces
i would just instantly be black yeah i
mean sometimes the rook is so good in
the ending and it's better than the the
two minor pieces but you do as you say
it's a nice point i think you need to
change off your bishop for another piece
to get that if you could eliminate these
two pieces from the board then black's
rook gains a lot of squares the problem
is uh yeah it's just where do you put
this rook uh literally nearly every
square is covered okay this is one of
the few i was gonna say this square is
covered um this square is covered this
square this way uh this square not
possible so you have to bring it forward
here but look at jordan attacking the
black rook now and
if the black route goes back would we
see a repetition of the position why
going forward maybe the black brook has
to choose somewhere else liam needs to
win you can't repeat i mean don't you
find this opening choice a bit strange
by liam i mean if it's known as a niche
the oracle knows everything says it's
actually a draw most time wouldn't you
have i praised it earlier i praised it
earlier but that's without knowing that
it's all been analyzed by computers yeah
i mean if you know that your opponent
has studied it before yeah it's maybe a
poor choice
easy in hindsight though to say these
things of course because you only know
after something's happened yeah and also
maybe liam was kind of trying to second
guess jordan and say well jordan also
needs to win if he wants to get up there
at the top of the standings so he didn't
expect this type of uh end game from him
but uh okay we see
liam move his rook
to attack the dark squared bishop that's
a weird square bit of an ugly square for
the but gaming time ugly yeah i guess
the idea is you gain time you hit the
white bishop and when the white bishop
moves you do have time to maybe push
harry the h point down the board to kick
away white's knight yeah normally you
don't want to put your rook on files
where they will be blocked you want them
on open lines like uh like whether rook
previously stood but it's all about
tempo gaining time i guess the kind of
thing that black would like to see here
we can just maybe quickly show it um is
if the white king travels towards the
bishop now which we mentioned earlier
and now black could get that exchange of
bishops off the board so the black rook
takes something the white king takes
something and this is going to benefit
black in general because you get down to
that rook versus two pieces the rook is
is a lot easier to deal with i mean even
here i'm not sure because the rook's out
of place but as a general idea that's
what black wants black wants to get rid
of one set of minor pieces especially uh
you mentioned simon it's the bishops
because we talk about the bishop pair
and okay white stepping back away from
that trade uh we talk about the bishop
here but actually here they're
phenomenally strong um these two white
bishops together if you can trade one of
them off no matter which bishop it is
you'll be happy the one thing you don't
want to do is trade off your black
bishop for the white knight you need to
trade off your bishop for your charge
bishop and he's trying yeah good move by
liam trying to force these off the board
if these bishops depart then maybe some
decent winning chances for black the
problem is if you don't go for that
trade uh if jordan just steps back with
his white bishop
then it's going to be hard to trade off
these pieces later yes you gain time to
kind of push forward kick away the white
knight but
the black brook it just feels so
misplaced i'm on an open line anymore i
would imagine duda is actually really
feeling quite happy at the moment he's
probably watching this chilling out and
he's thinking yeah i mean come on
jordan's not going to lose this position
because
i i don't think he should lose this
position with the white pieces so i
reckon he's a happy boy at the moment
and on that note simon let's head out to
svara any site of
duda sweater yeah i actually have him
right behind here if we can show the
camera on the backside i see him
watching together with amnes right now
they're following the screen
we also have ragnamba right here so it's
uh it's definitely a lobby that is
paying attention to this uh final game
here but i'm also kyle standing here now
together with johan sebastian
christensen who is the second of jordan
and this is a familiar position to you
yeah kind of it's the line we prepared
for for for this game
it's it's very solid not too many
and not really risking too much and just
playing very slow and
going for a long game and in the end
maybe catch catch like one but but you
know we're thinking a lot about the
tournament win right now but for jordan
this is it's quite a lot of places that
he can move either up or down regardless
on the on the spot he catches here if
for example he was to overpress for a
win right now
that would mean that suddenly it could
cost duda the win as well yes exactly
but uh i don't actually think jordan
thinks too much about it he's just
playing and trying to win and not really
thinking about who wins and who comes
second who comes further and so on
so right now we have a lot of people
watching the game going on on this
screen
but then there's also some people
watching a game going on at a different
screen
inside of the lobby there is also quite
a bit of action so right now there's a
lot of stuff going on but
our focus that is directed very much at
the chessboard right now
absolutely it's right out there i
thought i heard some shouting apparently
that was probably the manchester united
chelsea game going on
magnus carlsen we did see following that
but this is way more dramatic than that
premier league game
if liam wins this game he will win the
tournament any other results and duda
will win everything depends on this
final rapid game
in the oslo esports cup any hope for
liam here
he might need help liam in order to win
this game and it's exactly what anish
what johann sebastian was saying white
is just rock solid so it might depend on
a blunder from jordan for liam to win
this one and first of all there was a
trade of those light squared bishops we
said that that would probably help black
but black does have double pawns now on
the g file not ideal those pawns those
black horns they are right for the
picking at some point white's king can
go after them simon do you think this
trade has helped or still difficult
yeah i mean i i think i'd be a bit more
comfortable if i was black here because
it's one less bishop to worry about in a
position where that rook was in so much
danger so i i think i feel more relaxed
as in my plan is simpler i can just move
my work around okay i might lose a pawn
but i can just simply try to cause
trouble with that rook
but as you mentioned often the rook is
better than two minor pieces but in this
particular case the two minor pieces
they just work so well and with this
last move white is going to win a pawn
look at the bishop in the middle of the
board you can't really move that away
ever it's going to stay there for all
eternity and um
it's it's easier for white to play and
better i'd say a little bit better for
white uh but saying that draw most
likely and above them yeah i i have to
agree with you that simon i really do
think that the bishop and knight are
just working beautifully together but uh
the key is actually to keep the black
rook under looking key if you can
control the movement of its uh
just this movement then
it should be it should be actually fine
and maybe you can even push for more
yeah uh i definitely would be pushing
for more here if i were white and okay
really instructive move there from uh
jordan he brings the white king in and
uh it's definitely not the type of
position where you should be greedy if
you take this black pawn it looks like
you can get away with it but you do let
the black rook into your position and
suddenly the black rook might start
marauding might start taking some pawns
so first jordan just lifts his king up
covering entry any entry squares the
black rook wants to use and okay the
black crook has been given time to cover
this pawn so uh liam for now still
maintains all of his pawns intact but
yeah white has full control i mean one
move that i'm itching to play with white
and i've been itching to play for a long
time is to push this white pawn forward
and look at this bishop now simon
mentioned it's impossible to ever kick
it away and now that this black pawn
push has been uh just removed from the
equation by white's pawn being here this
bishop is an eternal peace and the
bishop the knight they do completely
lock out this
black rook so okay he's played it really
important strategic move very nice
positional one there and also these
black pawns now are fixed too so if the
white knight can sneak around behind and
grab them i think jordan will be a big
favorite but for now it's still in the
balance it's time for the black king to
join the party
very very important to do that teamwork
makes the dream work we've said that
many many times but in endgames it's
especially important yeah yeah i
actually like your idea david to bring
that knight around as well here i mean
like there's two black pawns on the
queen side which which are both weak and
if i was white here i i don't want to
move my bit i mean it's quite logical i
don't want to move my bishop bishop
fantastic i can't really move any of my
pawns my king is okay i could go towards
the g pawn but i don't see it really
helping um so what do i do logically the
only piece i can move is my knight
so then you look at the best square foot
of knight and you start maneuvering it
to better squares and well that's what
i'd be thinking maybe we can show the
root of that knight
well maybe c2 let's say and then i want
to go to e1 so black just waits for
example and then you drop back yeah and
then for example black just waits you go
forward and yeah you're starting to leap
towards these weak weaknesses
so it takes a while but there is a path
forward yeah and uh okay liam gives a
check instead hitting the white king uh
i don't know what his idea is if the
king moves forward i guess he wants to
deliver a check hitting the white king
but very worse comes to worse the king
can just step back and the black rook
still can't creep into the position
okay we see that on their screen as well
this is the current position um the
reason i say the king should step back
is because if you step forward taking a
black pawn then suddenly the black brook
finally gets to the second rank that's
its dream destination still not the end
of the world for white to be honest it's
still probably very good for white but
the more i'm looking the more
because really i really think great
actually great preparation by jordan
because even though anish said okay it's
probably a draw it's black who's always
going to make the drawing has to make
the draw in these positions and white
who's pushing so i i again i think duda
he's getting happier and happier the
more the game goes on and i would just
retreat here at least repeat the
position once i think white maybe has
other ways to do it but jordan he's not
as we've seen the most patient guy in
the world and he takes support he takes
the pawn okay allowing the black rook to
get active but i mean presumably i
thought his idea was going to be knight
takes born
okay um so actually there was a nice
tactic here as ivanka points out taking
this pawn off the board actually opening
up an attack against the black rook but
uh there i guess lots more pawns would
disappear maybe white wants to keep
pawns on the board so uh instead white
pushed this guy forward this is the
potential winner you know how it
promotes on a dart square in the corner
and after black captured this pawn
white's knight is jumping forward white
wants to remove this pawn from the board
and push his own trump card this pawn
later
so very difficult now this is the target
but also white's knight wants to jump in
with a nasty check the black pawns are
starting to drop obviously liam must be
nervous he knows that if he wins this he
wins the tournament
can jordan somehow play a little bit on
that
yes
yeah um i mean jordan i think that was
the opening choice uh you guys were
praising it a moment ago he chose an
opening where in order to create winning
chances liam has had to take some risks
he maybe could have locked things down
for a draw uh five six moves ago liam
maybe even before that but he needs to
win and uh yeah we saw
liam take some odd decisions and dude
looks very confident we must say um yeah
it's hard to imagine black ever winning
this position
just how do you ever win this position
white's pieces are too good the knight
in bishop yeah i must admit i'm
surprised that uh duder is uh so calm if
i were in his situation i i don't think
i would be able to even watch this game
though isn't it because
you know whatever happens
it's not in your control you've done
you've done your work so you can sit
back the stress is out and it doesn't
really matter okay that's true if you
don't if you don't win you've still done
brilliantly well um so you know i think
it's you know nice could the position be
about to come uh become complicated
though
liam here he does have one moment one
opportunity to push a pawn and at least
rid the white bishop of its dream square
and he's done it uh in this position we
just saw a capture here black pushing
forward it looked like a trade was about
to happen but if the black group goes
back and takes this pawn then white's
bishop finds its dream home in the
middle once more remember this pawn is
so dangerous and it might just win the
game for white therefore
liam said okay instead of taking this
pawn for now i'm going to leave it and
he pushes his own pawn these three pawns
are running but also this white pawn
running itself and this is just three
squares away from promotion now
looking complicated all the pawns should
disappear but liam is the one fighting
for the draw because white's pawn is the
most dangerous of the bunch i'd love to
i'd actually love to see this get down
to bishop and knight versus king one of
the one of the hardest sort of endings
to to master uh these guys should have
mastered it but um we could even see
that happening but look at it it's all
happening on the right hand side of the
board now this is the critical area at
the moment it's all about whether this
pawn can push through and promote but
for now it's locked down by the black
king black's king covers its square that
it wants to advance to so at the very
minimum if jordan just wants to draw he
could give a check for example the black
king could step back and he could take
this pawn
i mean this looks very natural to me to
be honest but you are running out of
pawns maybe this just this does give
black the time to just step back with
this rook for example maybe trade a set
of pawns
i mean what else do you play here if not
this check for white i don't really see
anything else to be honest
do you think this will this is edging
towards a drawer looks that way and at
this okay we do see the night check and
black's king has to continue blockading
the white pawn i don't think you should
go any other direction um this way just
looks illogical somehow
it's still fine because if you push
forward with the white pawn the bishop
drops but yeah why not blockade if you
can
why not blockade the white pawn
and if this is a draw that means we will
finish the tournament with tie breaks
you guys it's not going to decide the
tournament winner if this is a draw then
duda will win no matter what but we will
get some dramatic tie breaks to finish
off the oslo esports cup
yeah and in those tie breaks uh liam
would be fighting for second place i
guess yeah jordan also i mean some lots
of money at stake um still very high
stake tournament and uh okay one pawn
has dropped yeah and liam actually does
have to be a little bit careful because
there is a big thread on the board and
white is actually threatening to push
the king one square forward deprived
black of the black monarch of squares
and then threatens checkmate
yeah we should have to show this mating
net
in the current position because
as ivanka mentions big threat if black
is just careless um i'm looking for just
a random move then white's king steps
forward whoops again this knight check
is just terminal if you waste a move
with black then this is actually a
checkmate net
and i'm not sure the name of this
checkmate ivanka you're the expert there
but checkmate is checkmate and uh this
one is pretty bad for black this one's
called checkmate you're also an expert
as well simon i did do a video series on
it and you do yeah i know laurence trent
has actually
done some stuff for ginger gym where he
did an attack
yeah so like between all three of us we
should know all the names the spider web
checkmate
the norwegian spider the uh do you have
what kind of spiders does she have in
the week
gross ones like every other
so black's rook is coming trying to stop
this checkmate um i'm just wondering how
you stop it though for example if the
white king does march forward in this
direction re kind of reinstating this
threat of trapping the black king black
has to give a check literally nothing
else you can do and then the white king
may be moving this way you've got to be
careful now because if you keep checking
then white is going to kind of close the
net around the black king and suddenly
this would pretty much end the game
so you have to be really careful here as
black
in the current position i'm expecting
because of these incoming checks white
to start centralizing the king
still it feels like it should be a draw
with best play because there aren't too
many pawns remaining if black can remove
all these pawns from the board the left
side
then it should be a draw once those
pawns disappear black can actually use
his rook and go and give itself up for
this pawn and for the white bishop that
should secure the draw but you're
running out of time as black
white can still create some threats in
the process yeah
and also i was just thinking if the
white king runs all the way to the left
maybe there might be even possibilities
of trying to keep the white pawn alive
yeah so if white can keep one of his
pawns alive he's likely to win it just
depends on whether you can keep that
white pawn on the c3 square live that
might be the key pawn later on but if
black offers up a trade on that side
it's likely you might have to trade off
we'll see jordan
he knows that there's zero risk now for
white i think
which is good news for duda but uh yeah
he's looking for ways to win so jordan
basically he needs to keep both of his
pawns alive at least one of them okay he
wants to make black give up the black
rook for one of the pawns but he also
needs to keep uh both his minor pieces
the bishop knight and one of porn alive
it's kind of study like you get these
kind of studies that david showed
yesterday which are composed like
positions where you you know there's
this beautiful idea there and i imagine
jordan loves these kind of things you
know he's very good at uh finding the
tactics in certain positions so i i
think he'll i think he'll be pushing for
a while here uh i don't i again i as you
as you will mention i don't think liam
lee's chances of
winning a great uh the tournament i mean
something's gonna have to go wrong isn't
it if he's gonna win this now i think so
i think liam just needs a mouse slip or
something um yeah black can never really
win this position because at the very
minimum white's just gonna maybe give
some checks with the white knight the
black king is just a blockade a
defensive piece
and uh yeah the other end game we
mentioned there simon and
um one i'm hopeful we'll see as well is
white having a bishop and a knight
against just the black king love to see
that i mean i was watching a previous
show actually um where ivanka was lovely
you were demonstrating the the w
technique really
yeah
i remember that season i think i was at
home chilling out with a beer watching
you demonstrate it i was in the other
place and uh yeah i'm gonna be saying
how it happened it's super easy actually
oh i don't know about super easy it is
many grand masters don't know how to do
that yeah but because you just have to
remember it is quite geometrical uh once
you memorize the patterns but anyway
there's been a check about it it's going
up i don't know yeah okay i'm surprised
he went backwards jordan there because
uh i did show there was kind of a
checkmating idea in the position um if
white's king had gone forward i'm not
sure where the white king is going now
but uh yep either way liam did prevent
the immediate checkmate in one move
where white's knight was going to go
towards the black king now black's king
does have an escape square
so still heading towards the drawhand
yeah i disagree ivanka i think in
practice if you just have a board it's
really easy bishop tonight but imagine
in a game situation big crowd clock
ticking it's not easy at all i don't
know i think my method is pretty but
it's been some cases famous cases i mean
uh wasn't it in the women's world
championship yeah final where one of the
players couldn't checkmate with it one
of the biggest matches yeah
i mean she's i mean very strong the only
one
but i think it's because most people
like take a very practical approach they
go what are the chances i'm ever going
to get that checkmate
i don't need to learn it i'll figure out
over the board do you think jordan knows
how to checkmate with the bishop tonight
against the king yes i mean i remember i
remember once
actually it was laurence trent playing
against ivan sokoloff and it was a much
more complicated two nights and again
and the pawn
now two nights against the porn and a
king
and uh he was so upset with himself
because you know he knew the technique
and he just didn't quite do it well
laurence or lawrence no
okay we have just uh kind of bypassed an
interesting moment because jordan's
definitely playing for the win uh he
didn't trade off a set of pawns on this
left-hand side so white note how he
blocked things up with his own pawn so
he has one pawn remaining for later
jordan meanwhile just uh choosing his
playlist very relaxed there
choosing his song and black's pawn is
only two squares away from promoting but
it is stopped by white's bishop at the
top of the board look at the white
bishop it's got its eye the whole way
back down the diagonal stopping the
stopping the black pawn from pushing on
and a check first from liam yeah when in
doubt give a check good game technique
definitely i think liam has a really
crafty idea in mind he's going to carry
on checking the white king
and uh tempt it to go forward
okay so hitting the white king right now
tempting this king to go forward and if
it does step forward ivanka
yeah and i actually i wanted it to go
backwards first okay backwards first
yeah sorry you're asking a lot forwards
backwards sideways
it's been a long
week yeah simon so now rook check okay
and now
it's provoked you know now if the king
goes forward
say yeah now you can push a pawn yep now
you can push your pawn and yes the
bishop is uh kind of covering this
square but now the black rook also can
just capture the bishop so it's a bit
tricky where to put the king in uh sorry
in the current position here but uh if
the king goes forward same idea the
black rook will come down threatening to
push and uh this white bishop from afar
is a bit overworked defending its own
pawn and trying to stop black's pawn
it's very difficult for jordan if the
king comes towards the rook in this
manner i think the black rook will just
sidestep and same idea it's going to
drop down and kind of cover the second
rank for this pawn to push
it's interesting but it's very difficult
to see how white ever stops this pawn
now long term yeah it's also very
difficult to see how black will even win
even even if the best thing happens and
he wins the bishop yeah and okay a night
uh night block in this position the
white knight
blocking the check and black's rook just
sidestepping this is a really annoying
pin for white to break
and uh how do you break it that's the
problem for example if the king marches
forward this is a nice tactic then
suddenly black's rook can actually take
this pawn off because after the bishop
recaptures suddenly black makes a queen
this is maybe the only way that liam
could win this game if jordan forgets
about the pawn pushing forward but of
course jordan won't forget about that so
he doesn't go away with the white king
he goes back so still within distance
for example if that happens again of
black's pawn so the white king can ride
to the rescue now and stop this guy and
uh both sides are a bit stuck therefore
liam just waiting with the black king
and if he moves his knight backwards now
to try to cover that pawn in the best
way you can and then tries to move his
king towards the black pawn yeah that
that looks like um pretty decent winning
attempt to mean he hasn't got it for
this so and the point is i if it as
white if i can round up
that one annoying black pawn if i can
win that pawn and i want to bring my
king towards it and sort of suffocate it
and then take it well i should have
great great winning chances then but i
can put my king i mean on that square
then block with the knight we can maybe
show that uh happening
black just waits uh if black waits too
long then whoops you cut the
coordination between the black brook and
the black pawn and slowly but surely you
grab this guy then you go up and same
thing again you eventually round up this
black uh this blackboard
okay wow liam is playing with fire he's
marching forward with the black king and
catch up with the game maybe he wants to
win this position still this is maybe a
mistake uh how is this a mistake because
uh okay now that the king has uh
retreated i was thinking that the rook
would come down to the first row just to
you know pin the knight
maybe you can actually just sidestep and
just go king to
yep the king could much forward here
because you can't actually take white's
knight suddenly the black king because
it's run away this pawn promotes on the
next turn it's all about the pawns
white's pawn black's pawn who's going to
make the queen
in the current position though liam
found a nice move he's cut off the white
king on the second rank i think this is
the key move yeah stopping the white
king advancing now and this check from
white
the question is now back or forward
into the center brave courage or safety
first
he goes back backwards yeah but that
means he can't really win this game if
you're going back
and uh i think he's given up his hope of
winning i i feel liam at the moment i
think he's going for the draw and
realizes that you know that's that's the
best he can get here can you admit it
though
do you need help if the white king
jordan's much closer than liam to win it
if the white king as simon mentions is
able to step up onto the second rank and
win that black pawn then white's
definitely winning not even a question
you know
trying to stifle a smile maybe yeah he
knows he is getting so close to winning
the oslo esports cup
he started out losing the match to
magnus carlsen and here he is
getting close to winning the whole thing
imagine he started out losing to magnus
on day one also to one f3 and we talk
about karma interests imagine the
heartbreak of losing to an opening like
that but then coming back and winning
the event he's putting those ghosts to
bed
so if duda wins it which is looking very
likely now then he's deserved it yeah
and uh duda actually had
didn't even get any birthday luck either
you know turns 24 and he loses in a tie
break to liam
who now he's kind of hoping can
can not win this game he's been the king
of the tie breaks dude there's so many
tie breaks uh he won most of them and uh
other than against liam of course but uh
yeah i mean he's a fighter calls himself
the polish fighter and
yeah
in favors those who fight right now
jordan trying to go back to the center
with his knight i'm not sure where that
knight's going i think well really the
only piece that white can use to try and
win this position is the knight he can't
really use his king he can't use his
bishop so
he's trying to find somewhere for his
knight to go to but i like this move
from liam who who attacks that pawn um
and now just simply comes back asking
the question uh okay where actually are
you going to go with that knight you can
only attack one pawn uh i'll defend it
i'd imagine yeah if the knight ever
moves from where it's at right now black
will go back after white's pawn on the
cease fire there is there is what about
this idea actually you just give up the
protection of the h6 pawn and you just
go right let's uh let's bank on charlie
yeah seahorn of course
and and you've also got a very maybe
some checkmate idea and bringing the
knight back if you you know at some
point as a there's a funny checkmate
there maybe we can just show it let's
say uh the rook defends the pawn for
example in this position yeah just for
example it's probably a bad move but
just to show uh and now the knight comes
in to attack the pawn again
and the rook goes back let's just say
because it's a pretty pattern and now
the knight can of course take the pawn
which is good but the check is quite
tempting
and the king goes in the corner
and the bishop check makes it and i just
like these patterns i mean that was like
basically with the worst possible play
that black could ever do a lot of help
a lot of help black had to self-made
himself but it's a pretty pattern and we
like our pretty patterns that was used
against me
what's that one called we've got to give
that one a name don't we anyone any any
advice gonna be the kaya mate because i
would fall into that yeah well yeah we
could you could call it the kaya mate
yeah thank you or we could even ask
people in the chat as well but kaya
mate's quite earthquake i quite like the
kaya mates
yeah i would fall into that every single
time meanwhile a nice move from liam we
should say keeping an eye on this pawn
so fixing down the white knight the
white knight has to keep protecting that
pawn and uh the problem for jordan is if
he ever gets greedy with his own bishop
then suddenly the king is let out of his
box the king can remove this important
pawn and yeah the king will just journey
over and it should be a simple draw
there's no way really to push this pawn
forward
while also winning black's pawn black's
pawn is a thorn in white side and
actually the position has repeated
itself and uh okay i was going to say if
liam brought his rook back that would
have been the second time we saw that
position may be headed towards the draw
but liam says no i don't even need to do
that i can't wait for the black part the
bar has gone crazy and i'm just having a
look at the computer as to why it's gone
crazy and it says that it's winning for
whites because of this move okay why now
the idea is if rook takes porn this is a
nasty night fork you've walked into the
wrong square your king and rook are
within touching we're going to see the
kaia mate it could be the kind of you
guys okay what is happening here so the
black king is step back to safety and
wow this is amazing the winning idea is
a check from the white knight the king
marches back and now you just move the
bishop he hasn't found it jordan it's
not easy you just move your bishop out
of the way somewhere you guard this
square the black rook wants to use and
you actually give up your night wow wow
that was a tough one difficult to spot
very different here the idea is that the
white knight drops but the white pawn
steps forward and no way to prevent a
new queen
that was difficult
duda reacting to all of this i'm curious
to see him right now that was getting
very close for duda he is looking very
calm
but it's getting close for him oh i see
a smile slight smile there
yeah you know it is edging towards the
draw that's how tricky it is when your
opponent has a knight just one small
slip if you put your king and rook on
the wrong square you walk into danger uh
but yeah i mean that one
maybe in an over the board game long
game he would have found it he still has
five minutes or had five minutes jordan
but it's so hard to just kind of change
the pace and notice that one moment
i feel like that mate was so beautiful
it's like if if chess were like a
sporting kind of thing it would have an
action replay look at this it's so
wonderful i think you should get extra
points for pretty mates exactly that's a
good idea
how do you like finish it but that would
force people to resign early to avoid
the extra points that were that you
can't resign of course you're not
allowed to resign
and it's i think is it i know you need
your knight at the top of the board i
think again what the bar has easy but if
he moves the bishop now can you do it i
know because then you have to guard the
pawn actually maybe yeah maybe you can
repeat the position you can go back
where you came from
still for that same trick
i mean
what are we looking at the same trick
so this trick is in the position for
jordan to win this game he has to play
this knight check that's actually the
most obvious move in the position but
it's not that one it's the second move
which is most difficult planting the
night on this square uh remember there's
a night check here there's a night check
there we've had this position before and
uh okay the stockfish there i think uh
maybe not spotting the horizon uh the
horizon's not deep enough and as
mentioned this is the killer blow the
knight check the king move but this is
the difficult one to see it's like four
moves in advance so we can't blame
jordan if he doesn't find it but
dropping the white bishop back covering
this square that the black rook wants to
use and also after the king takes to
push forward with his pawn he's found
the first move oh he's found the second
he's found him
if he finds this he's a genius this is
the move he has to find a knight check
and he wins the game
he
keeping us on tender hooks
it goes back to like you've got to look
at all the checks you know it's that
basic rule um check the checks out and
uh check the forcing boost so uh he
should have he should have considered it
for longer considering his time the
thing is he's still got a winning
position after the king moved so after
white's knight came to protect his pawn
um this move bringing the knight back
would win except he's had that position
twice before so that would be the third
time so it's a winning move but it would
allow an immediate draw and okay the
white bishop steps back and we've had
this position before as well second time
we've seen this position
brings this bishop back it's a draw
all right let's uh take a look at judo
now with this uh it could be a drawn out
with this next move could well be it's
looking very likely
i'd love to see him celebrate can you
imagine him running around we see a
smile
did you see a smile on dude's face this
next move can decide if he wins the oslo
esports cup right the game goes off
the suspense is
so hard
i think a draw is almost inevitable now
unfortunately but yeah the game goes on
white's goal to try and win this game is
to push the white pawn forward far
enough that the black rook has to
sacrifice sacrifice itself for that
white pawn but the problem is the black
king is coming over now and no matter
when you start moving the white knight
white bishop around
yeah black will get an opportunity to uh
bring a
king over give up the pawn for uh give
up the rook for a peace and the pawn
white king is just in the cage that's
the problem white's king is just
terrible not participating
it's pretty simple draw now i think and
we're going to see it probably happening
in the next minute or two the only trap
is not to walk into a night fork no
night checks yes that hit the black king
and the black rook at the same time
what kind of celebration do you think
we're going to see from dude
do you think he's going to do the double
fist pump is he going to do the mexican
wave celebration a little bit of ronaldo
ronaldo watch off running around the
hallway he's saying what was it was he
uh his same
bolt
he said
maybe the in-betweeners dance we were
looking at earlier oh yeah should we do
that together
no no
wow jordan's about to give up his knight
he's about to push his pawn forward and
that's actually a great winning attempt
i don't think it wins but here we go we
could see some flashy end uh to this
game white's knight is under fire from
the black rook but he pushes the pawn
forward so now if black goes and uses
the black rope captures the white knight
white will win white's pawn pushes
forward and there's no way to stop it
you have to bring the black king back
now surely
is that the only defense maybe we can
see the stockfish moves now
i think if you take this white knight
you lose and okay he found the best move
okay he could have made another option
as well but the black king is just in
time to go back and stop this pawn
we're heading towards a
draw in this game that means tie breaks
it also means duda wins the tournament
and liam lee must be very aware of that
right now he has been fighting hard
trying out different stuff he's tried
and yeah unfortunately not enough jordan
just too solid
the opening choice may be wrong for liam
this is the last trick and and liam has
covered it straight away i think he was
hoping for the king to retreat when
actually white would have won again but
with this move it's a draw black rook
locks it down and actually white here
has to be slightly careful you have to
go for the draw immediately because
white's bishop and white's knight are
attacked at the same time a little bit
of nervous time for duder then you know
still two moves away dude now from
winning the tournament oh you know a
draw is inevitable now after the bishop
disappears everything's disappearing
it's king vs king double fist
young christoph duda wins the oslo
esports cup we see some
congratulations from his fellow players
let's get let's get duda